[Music]
how many of you guys are fans of the wwe
ironically when i was a kid oh my god
when it was wwf
yeah i don't know now what what's the
difference what other than the name
change what was the difference between
wwf and
cw and wwf combined and
and honestly a lot of the talent kind of
got together coagulated and um but still
the good ones rose to the top like
undertaker was always relevant like
yes china was my hero oh china
i forgot about it yeah when she died
years ago
didn't she have a big [ __ ] she had a
huge [ __ ] all right well
we're seeing that on lively sorry it was
pretty big
i remember gargantuar because i thought
she had like is it because she was on
steroids
oh i think it was what happens when
you're on steroids your foot turns into
a penis
you get a pinky-sized [ __ ] they get like
big puffy nipples
and some of them even lactate yeah yeah
but that means she comes really hard
because her [ __ ] nervous nerve system is
huge
it's kind of like a fountain imagine
you know how hard it is to find the [ __ ]
guys like you know what i'm saying
speaking of the room imagine having a
[ __ ] [ __ ] the size of a pinky
and you still don't find it
i can't find it anywhere but imagine
you come in her and then she comes on
you
oh that's pretty cool well it's girl
come
i'm down girl comes cold yeah yeah i
don't know man we call it gum
gum yeah i got squirted on one time it
was weird i love being squirted off
oh my gosh does it feel like you've been
peed on yeah
well you're just confused in general
like what's happening right now like
what
oh what's going on was compare and
contrasting i didn't get squirted on
because i was on top she just wet the
bed oh
that's what happened to me but it was
like squirted on is
i'm imagining it was on top and it
poured on you
so yeah i was on top but she she was
like coming up on me
yeah yeah it feels good it was warm
yeah but then i was like
you should have warned me like we got we
could have got like
a a towel and i asked my friend this
like is this normal like
what's going on i think my girlfriend
just peed on me is that normal
is this normal i just made a woman come
it doesn't mean that we can't
doesn't mean we can't do that right
and then so i like i asked a couple of
my friends and my friend was
one of my friends like oh yeah yeah like
my girlfriend does that all the time
and then i was like so like what do
y'all do and he's like oh i get a a
grocery bag
and i put it under don't you need
something that absorbs what the [ __ ]
imagine she's at the store and every
time she gets the bag she's like i'll
take another one
so what about the undertaker oh right
right back
under her butt i like this
no the reason why i brought up wwe is
because in
india they've launched a new
spectacle uh that shares a lot of
similar
similarities to wwe and the fact that
wwe is supposed to be some form of
wrestling or like a
bombastic version of regular wrestling
bombastic i've never heard anyone use
that outside of a song
true or news articles
mr fantastic
that's sick what does it mean uh
outlandish
oh mr bombastic get it now what is it
iwf like indian wrestling federation
it's called all kabody world
that's the name of this facebook page
who is now
releasing content of this over-the-top
version of
indian wrestling and it comes though
because the bodybuilding scene is huge
out there
is there really i don't know if the
bodybuilders are
our bodybuilders aren't doing the
wrestling no i have a video here so
their wrestlers look different than ours
they probably look like nacho libre you
will be the judge of this
okay yeah those different kind of
wrestling yeah yeah it's indian
wrestling it's like an ancient
art oh they've decided to take that
wrestling sport and turned it into more
of an entertainment thing
oh what it looks like if i hear
bollywood music i'll lose my [ __ ]
it got darker
how soft is that
what the [ __ ] is happening
i gotta say that's weird i went down the
rabbit hole yesterday i watched i
watched like i think like a straight
hour of this you just watch
an hour of dudes slapping each other's
chest yeah
this is like this is like when i watched
marble racing and i was like this is so
stupid i'm going to watch this for four
hours
marble racing marble racing you mean
like marbles
marbles little marbles and the the
announcer is the best part of it the
announcer is like
telling you who's in pole position
this marble does that so it's like a big
horse racing it's like really good too
it's going down like a track or
something going down a track that's it
well wait what's the strategy if you're
not doing anything at that point
there's no strategy it's absurdity
that's you okay strategy
yeah it's like that strategy yeah each
other strategic it's literally
slapping back and forth how do you win i
don't know i watched it for so long and
i was trying to figure out what the
rules are what what the pattern was it
was just slapping slapping
slapping and did they count the flaps
maybe i don't know i think it's like wwe
it's more like theater
yes yes favorite [ __ ] in wwe is when you
see a guy get slammed and he hits the
the back right yeah and he goes ah
goddamn
he immediately does that it's like
choreography they do every time i like
when they hit
and they like stomp on the floor oh yeah
that's right oh yeah
yeah but when they land on something
they bounce really hard like yes
but yeah so it seems like they're just
slapping each other
and having a good time and like a lot
like if you look closely in the videos a
lot of the referees are just smiling too
and then like
i was watching it and some of the even
some of the wrestlers are kind of like
laughing at themselves when they're
getting slapped and they're they're
bracing for it too because these are not
like fake slaps they're real slaps yeah
but it's not a real competition so
they're
really just engaged with just like they
were slapping each other hard though
some guys were hitting each other in the
face
i was thinking they're going to knock
each other out you ever seen those
slapping
competitions russian [ __ ] slapping
competitions
they knock each other out did you see
that one with a big ass dude and that
skinny ass tattooed kid
they got rocked [ __ ] whacked them so
hard
man this seems like just a bunch of
dudes getting together having fun
it looks fun it looks fun i like the
fact they're in like this like
it's very it feels very communal and
like you see a lot of kids in the
background and like
wait so you're saying this was like a
traditional indian wrestling so this is
this stems from a very ancient art of
wrestling called
kabati and now so this little body on
your body since because have you seen
those videos of like indian cops they
don't arrest you or anything they just
slap the [ __ ] out of you if you do
something wrong
really really martial art yeah i saw a
video i think of them
like someone was not wearing a mask so
the indian cops came over what the [ __ ]
are you doing just slap the [ __ ] out
that's like how you shame people
oh [ __ ] they slap the [ __ ] out of you i
like how the concept of masculinity over
there
is very different from ours because over
here it's like it's more masculine to
wrestle a guy
punch him in the face kick him whatever
over there just it's like
yeah it's it's it's manly thing to slap
each other in the [ __ ] well the high
five is also different because joe
witnessed the high five when it was
addicted
yeah they held hands and then they went
like how cute
they hold hands and pinkies when they
walk around yeah yeah yeah
yeah russell peters had this bit where
like it was like um
so best friends there this is in austin
texas by the way they hold
they hold hands like with their pinkies
like this and their best [ __ ] friends
but he was like there was an indian
street gang out there full of tough guys
but because they're still best friends
they were holding pinkies
while they were staring at him and like
being threatening so he was so confused
he feels like these best friends are
like swinging pinkies and [ __ ] it's very
scary
they're like going like this and they're
staring at him like what's up
oh that's [ __ ] scary it's scary to
like i might get [ __ ] kind of way yeah
like you're not sure if you want to beat
me or [ __ ] me not [ __ ] up but [ __ ]
in the ass yeah
yeah it is weird because i feel like
india has it's like china right where
there's a lot of people
that they don't need anyone else and
anyone else's culture
they have their own thing going on we're
like the rest of the world is kind of
influenced by
america or just each other and then
we're kind of a blend of all that stuff
but then when you think about those
countries they
been their own thing for like a long
long time and yeah they might like adopt
the dressing for like thousands of years
yeah but they're like a different world
completely like you go there and
the the idea of like what it is to be a
woman or a man or like the style and
whatever and the roles and everything is
just like out of this [ __ ] world
that's true yeah is there betting
involved in this
i saw a clip where the winner of the
match
ended up collecting money from different
people that would walk up to himself oh
[ __ ] there is something how do you even
win
i don't know he slept better than you
i wanna win yeah well that's the
that's the theatrical version of kabaddi
and i actually went out of my way to
track down what ryoka body looks like at
least in the modern sense
oh it's an actual sport in india see
maybe maybe these guys are mad
at the kabaddi guys because they're like
you are tainting
or ancient sport you know what the the
theatrical version seems to
be more ancient looking the fact that
it's in like a dirt ring
they're like down to their underwear and
they're like topless and they're just
like wrestling and stuff
so it feels a little more like like a
traditional
because the the modern day kabody like
in terms of the sport one
whoa looks more like this oh it's crazy
i have no idea how they play it but they
they have to do a thing they have to do
a thing called a raid
they're so they're raiding him wait oh
it's two against one
right what well the rest of the team's
on this side like
what wait who's on whose team it seems
like red rover like
you have to send like a representative
to the other side
get into the line or something you could
stop them from running or
i don't that's called getting jumped
dude his face is like i don't even know
what this game is
i just what is this game man i put on
the jersey i don't know what's going on
it looks like don't get jumped
it does it looks like tag at first and
then it looked like dodge ball
and then there's like multiple people
maybe it's like dodgeball where you get
canceled out and then it's like last man
standing
or maybe maybe ice skate booth is a
professional version of everything
yeah like dodge ball tag yeah like true
it's absurd
the ocho ultimate frisbee that's such a
frat bro thing
i played frisbee golf one time it was
most miserable
it's where you you have to kick a ball
and order a soccer golf
soccer goal yeah you're just making that
up kick a ball in a hole
they have like soccer sized holes cause
kickball is like baseball and then
soccer
yeah but you like kick it and you know
it's very hot
foreign